[Music]
all right matinee show yeah we saw some
pretty good ones this should be a pretty
good show yeah I did a shudder did a
Netflix yeah and did a theater which
ones we cover and today we are doing
bliss yeah what did Jack do yeah and the
rhythm section yeah alright so the first
we're going to talk about is bliss now
this actually came out I believe in
October of 2019 yeah but it just now hit
shudder so I know it's like a little bit
older than usually we would do for this
show but I'm just getting around to
seeing it get shudder just out of it so
we're gonna talk about that one now this
movie is okay this is what would happen
if you mixed you took the movie Mandy
some Dario Argento the old movie thirst
the thirst I think it was called with
Lily Taylor about the vampire drug
addict thing if you took those three
movies and put them in a blender and
blended them all together and then like
put some punk rock on top of it that's
kind of what this would be like so how
you feel about that is how you're gonna
feel about this movie because I will say
I really dug this movie but I can see
how one it's very style of her substance
I mean it's a very simple story it's
basically about this woman named desi
and she's an artist and she's kind of
like having a shitty like time in her
career like she's kind of lost her mojo
she's working on this one painting and
she can't she's not getting any
inspiration for it her agents gonna drop
her because she's behind like on this
painting that she's supposed to deliver
the gallery and she spent all her
advance and all this other kind of [ __ ]
so she decides that she's gonna go to
her dealer oh and also her landlord is
bothering her about the rent like she
hadn't paid the rent in a couple months
and he's gonna kick her out so she just
decides [ __ ] it and she's gonna go to
her dealer and buy some drugs so now her
dealer has this really cool new drug
called bliss which what did he say it
was it was a combination of cocaine and
something else I can't remember what it
was but it was basically like maybe it
was that I can't remember offhand but it
was just like some supercharged like
cocaine and she like takes a sample that
she's like huh yes please so she buys
some off
know how much it is baby not if that's
like that she could have paid her rent
check with it for whatever and basically
as it goes on at least you're a led to
believe that this drug because she just
keeps like taking it man
and it does like cause her to get some
inspiration for her painting but it also
causes her to blackouts and maybe murder
people and you start drinking blood and
whatnot so that's not good she's having
some threesomes there were some
threesome yeah there is just all kind of
fun [ __ ] in this so like I said it's a
very simple story in the sense that it
is her you know getting like all into
this drug and you know basically I don't
know if I'd say turning into a vampire
but I guess sort of it's sort of like a
vampire movie like I said it reminded me
a lot of like the thirst that Lily
Taylor maybe they came out in the 90s or
something I remember when it was it was
a long time ago I thought but it has
like a veneer like pretty much the first
half of the movie this is not a super
long movie it's only 80 85 minutes
something like that our detail yeah it
did seem kind of long I did just because
I think like I said the story is very
similar so a lot of it is just kind of
like a music video pretty much I mean
the score is cool there's like a lot of
really good like that
death rock [ __ ] like that going on in it
which I liked you guys notice and I'm
not saying anything right yeah but it's
like this is definitely and I will say
to you and I've heard some other
reviewers say this that how you feel
about this movie is gonna be how do you
feel about the main character now it's a
good acting performance in the sense
that you know people like this because
she's kind of like this is like the
underbelly of LA pretty much the whole
first half as the movie is spent in like
scuzzy like punk rock bars drug dens I'm
not sure when it said she has a flip
phone so I'm thinking maybe night late
90s early 2000 something I was hard to
tell I think you think of certain areas
to California frozen in time I mean I
left there in 1981 glad I never went
back I just thought because of the
phones I thought Carson I I did not
think that it was like said in the
modern day they don't really specify it
doesn't really matter but it's like I
did notice that she had a flip phone
instead of like a modern
cell phone so it's like hey like Pookie
is shot please stop chewing on that but
yeah so so how you feel about this is
gonna be like how do you feel about
watching a bunch of not particularly
likeable character it's not very
interesting you've hanging around like
having threesomes Hank getting high
getting drunk like yelling at people and
[ __ ] like that
I didn't mind it's like reality TV for
me it was way I can see how people like
this would kind of tend to avoid him so
he waved him into club there all right
at the club you don't wanna go home with
him so like the whole movie is full I
will say a George went from you know
norm from Cheers makes a cameo
appearance in this as desease dad uncle
somebody I don't know it's like somebody
that hangs out like where she goes to
get drugs I'm not real sure what the
relationship between all of these people
are so it's pretty much just kind of
like it was written and directed by a
guy named Joe Bay goes or Bay goes I'm
not really sure how to pronounce it but
you can tell that this is kind of like
his homage to this kind of like scuzzy
underground drug scene and so a lot of
the movie does revolve around that's not
a story based kind of thing you might
not like a lot of the characters it
takes a while to get where it's going
because like I said it doesn't have a
lot of story a lot of it's very visual
it up like trippy visuals yeah that's
yeah you hit right on the head there it
violated my ten-minute rule if I don't
know what the movie is about or you know
what I mean if I haven't been hooked in
the first 10 minutes I go ahead and tune
out yeah it means I'm not gonna like the
rest of the movie and and that is [ __ ]
99% accurate yeah
99% I be the only one that kind of
pushed that boundary today a rhythm
section almost pushed that 10 yeah but
what's yeah every day the movie once it
started rolling yeah but ya know this
this one was boring it did like I liked
it but like I said it's you have to it's
more like an experiential I saw another
like reviewer called experiential in the
sense that this is just something you're
gonna watch let the visuals and the
that kind of wash over you you don't
really have to pay attention to the
story particularly because you know it's
basically like you know she's painting
this stuff I had the feeling of a made
up as you go along slice-of-life movie
it was kind of like Baghdad for too long
I'm like it gave me a little bit of that
what's the weird [ __ ] what's that
weird [ __ ] movie that we watch from
the 80s that's just about like the
aliens that came down and wanted to do
heroin but it was just ya know a guy
like what's guys but liquid sky was
quite interesting yeah that gave me a
little bit of that vibe yeah um the best
of the movies we're talking about along
this lines would have been like that new
once upon a time in Hollywood yeah it's
kind of like a slice-of-life movie but
every one of those characters is
compelling yeah and everything that
everything that once upon that time in
Hollywood did write this movie did wrong
yeah there's somatic Adonis thematically
it's kind of similar to the devil's
candy even though that was a really
really good movie look at look at pokey
she's like I want to be on the show
dammit
but yeah so but you know it in the sense
that it's like you know an artist who's
like has inspiration and like has
blackouts and paints like evil looking
[ __ ] um there is like a lot of gore in
this there's like some you know there's
nudity there's that kind of thing but
like I said it's this gonna be like a
real divisive type of movie I didn't
mind it but I probably wouldn't watch it
again like I said if you want kind of
like you know more of like an artist
possessed like death metal type of movie
I would recommend the devil's candy cuz
that's a lot better and has like a lot
more compelling characters but you know
if you have shudder and you don't the
movie looked good yeah it's cool look at
a movie looked good it had good acting
in it I guess it was acting yes if that
you know I believe the characters that I
saw yeah but I just thought it was kind
of boring yeah it's just like I said I
can I can see how that it might have
worked better as a short film yeah
because you know after a while you it's
like yeah the trippy visuals are cool
and everything but you were kind of like
yeah okay like the drug is like messing
her up and she's like starting to want
to drink blood or there's nothing there
yeah so it's just kind of like it's
expanded out to movie lengths but like I
said if that sound
like something you'd be into then and if
you have shudder then go ahead and check
it out
all right now the second one I want to
talk about just kind of popped up on
Netflix very recently it's a short film
I was actually going to talk about
another short film that was on shudder
called the Whistler but then I decided
to do this one instead just because the
Whistler is good it's just that um it
wasn't anything like super mind-blowing
or anything like that and I was like
well I've been asked to do what would
Jack do because it's a 17-minute film
David weird I don't even know if I
understood it I was laughing too the
whole thing though is it's a monkey
talking about a chicken and monkey
trying to [ __ ] a chicken that any dude
judging them on it or something that and
the monkey was singing and it's it's
it's black and white it's [ __ ]
hilarious that in the monkeys serious
yeah it's like you just gotta see it
it's a Jenni explaining yeah it's like
seriously this is I mean obviously how
you feel about David Lynch is going to
like you know really inform your how you
received this is ridiculous this one
it's kind of like concentrated David
Lynch yeah so it's like some if you
don't want to sit like through the three
hours of Inland Empire or anything like
that but you just want like a short
sharp shock of David Lynch weirdness
then this is what you need to do like I
said it's 17 minutes long it was
actually made a few years ago is made
back in 2016 or 2017 and it premiered at
a French film festival cuz the French
[ __ ] loved David Lynch so he's always
doing like film [ __ ] over there so it
premiered over there and that it finally
just like dropped on Netflix in 2020 I
believe on David Lynch's 75th birthday
so basically the plot if you can call it
that David Lynch is playing I assume
like some kind of Detective and they're
in what appears to be like a locked down
train station and he is interviewing a
monkey yeah about a murder that has
taken place and during the course of
this very strange non sequitur filled
interview it comes to light that the
monkey whose name is Jack Cruise if you
wondered it even says is gonna see the
crazy as a human voice a human
it's a charming monkey it is he is very
charming yeah it comes to light that he
killed or he may have killed somebody
named max I don't know if max is a human
or another monkey but apparently he
killed him over a chicken that he's in
love with that's named to toda bond
that's the chicken's name yes right so
um I immediately I got gonzo vibes cuz
you know on the Muppets like gods I was
always performing with all the chickens
and some people have speculated that
he's kind of like into this one
particular chicken who's him it's
Camilla or something I camera with the
chicken's name is but so so that made me
laugh like the whole thing about like
this little monkey and then the monkey
breaks out into song and does a musical
number and everything and it's like it's
very like 20s their 30s yeah he tried to
make it look like what I thought to
myself other than like I've kind of
given up on trying to plumb the depths
of David Lynch's imagination because
he's just like well the thing about
David Lynch and I might have talked
about this some when I reviewed
Mulholland Drive
it's like he's a very um he doesn't
think too much about things he's very
like instinctual so a lot of the stuff
that he does
yes he's making it up as he goes along
but because he is so like well-versed in
narrative structure and film and things
like that a lot of times even the [ __ ]
that he just kind of pulls out of his
ass like ends up kind of making like a
strange kind of sense um so this one I
almost got the feeling that he wanted to
make because he's very into like
deconstructing the tropes of a
particular genre like he did on Twin
Peaks he wanted to take a soap opera and
like it you know intersperse it with
like surrealism you know what I mean so
what he did with this one was he took
like a lot of the tropes of like the
noir genre and it sounds like a lot of
the lines of dialogue because a lot of
this interview that they are conducting
between him and this monkey it's like it
doesn't really gel in the sense that
he's asking a question and sometimes
what the monkey says doesn't seem to
answer that question so it almost seems
like he took like a bunch of dialogue
from old like Dashiell Hammett like
books or movies or something like that
and then
like he just kind of like chopped him up
and like put them all in there it does
kind of make sense but not really I
think it was all just a bunch of
one-liners it was just Impressionism
Impressionism yeah it's almost kind of
like a deconstruction so it's like he's
actually just kind of like a weird
satire or a weird postmodern
reproduction of a scene I did yeah I
definitely do think that that's just to
give a characters chance to pontificate
and to perform it was just [ __ ] weird
it was LSD might have helped you know
what it's a and he made it like he aged
it like to make it look old like it came
from back then as well and like the way
it's shot is very much like an old noir
film where it's just kind of like
close-up of this guy close-up this guy
it's like really high contrast and it's
like really cool but it's like it's got
like some kind of weird like unsettling
kind of imagery he's like I saw some
people that reviewed it that said that
they actually didn't know like ahead of
time that the monkey was gonna talk
because so he's like so he's like David
Lynch is here talking to the monkey and
then all of a sudden there's a close-up
on the monkey and the monkey starts
talking like in his mouth moves they did
it like it looked like rotoscoping or
something like that just like they used
to do with Clutch Cargo yeah it looks a
lot better
um so watching like a little capuchin
monkey like talking like a human is a
little bit yeah and he has like a little
suit on and it's like he's making little
like serious expressions and [ __ ] like
that so it's like unsettling but also
kind of like hilarious it's sick so it's
like it looks like the monkey is talking
and singing it really does and it's like
kiss his eyes and everything because I
guess Wayne sometimes yeah because I
guess what he did was maybe he kind of
like you know took the dialogue that he
wanted to put in there and he put it in
there like that so it would like match
up with what the monkey was doing at the
time like if the monkey was looking over
there looking up or yeah or if he looked
to his people or something
he was voicing over the monkey yes I'm
not sure I heard that that was David
Lynch that that was David Lynch's voice
as well although I couldn't I couldn't
quite tell if it was it was like you
know he would like kind of disguise it
could sound kind of raspy but it's just
like and and there one scene where like
they show the chicken running and it's
like doesn't really
like it looks like kind of like a weird
surreal like it's too fast or some
frames are missing or something like
that it's like really really
strange-looking
where you see like two total bond like
running through the thing but it's just
like as I said if you're into surrealism
if you're into David Lynch I'd laughed
my ass off at this [ __ ] I just thought
it was funny as hell it's like I wish he
would make another full-length movie
because I don't know how like you guys I
mean Mulholland Drive is still probably
my favorite but it's like I loved Inland
Empire I loved all [ __ ]
three-and-a-half hours of that or
however long it was that was like one of
the creepiest movies I ever saw but this
one less creepy more funny although it
did make me want to watch Eraserhead
again yeah it gave me an eraser head
kind of vibe yeah it's not long this
reviews probably longer than a damn
movie yeah just go ahead and and watch
it and just be entertained it probably
means something but it does mean
something to him yeah it's only 17
minutes it's on Netflix it's like if you
like saving money it's just it's funny
it's like weird it doesn't make a lot of
sense and if you like to raise your head
or anything like that they you should
definitely go check it out check it out
because that is like it really gave me
an eraser head vibe and I was like man I
need to watch a racer head again that
was what I'm writing me up also I want
to watch this again because that monkey
is like [ __ ] adorable monkey [ __ ]
a chicken yeah that's what yeah that's
what he was getting too well yeah that's
kind of it was a love triangle between a
monkey a chicken and in a murder victim
somebody who may or may not be and if I
think it was just made up I think it's
kind of made up on a spot and it worked
out yeah on Netflix
you
all right third new movie we saw this in
the theater someone actually asked us to
go see this one so yeah so we did
actually goes because we'd only see the
trailer a couple times this is the
rhythm section yeah it's it's made by
the same people who make the
double-oh-seven you know there yeah the
producer is like yeah cuz she's well I
think cubby broccoli used to be have the
thing but I think he died so maybe
that's she's his widow I can't remember
how it goes but yeah so what okay
the weird thing about this is that like
I said I don't read reviews or anything
like that before I go see the movie so I
didn't know until after we saw the movie
that apparently this was Paramount
Pictures worst wide opening weekend of
all time and they think that paramount
is gonna lose 40 million dollars on this
baby because of this movie yeah which is
strange because we have a hold on backup
what are you saying you saying this is
Paramount's worst opening season ever
ever well that's because they're all
they look what what they make it's not
just Paramount's all of them but it's
like it's weird to me but bacon it's not
it's not like this is some lost
masterpiece or anything but this is a
perfectly watchable no this is a good
movie but they didn't really promote
this too much they promoted all kinds of
other crap that nobody's gonna say but
it's just yeah it just seems strange to
me that it's like that it's like that I
mean you know it's not like a super
original premise it's like okay so it's
based on a novel by Mark Bernal and he
also writes a screenplay now it was
directed by Reed Morano
um I think she did the first either just
the first or the first few episodes of
The Handmaid's Tale so um I don't know
if this is her first movie direction or
not but it's basically about this woman
named Stephanie and her whole entire
family is killed in a plane crash and
over the course of the movie she kind of
like goes through various thing it
things in order to like get revenge on
the terrorists that cause yeah check
this out alright you can Chryst a lot
you can crystallize this then we when we
watched it and then we walked out of it
I guys see what they did okay they
to make a spy movie like doublet like
James Bond yeah but not that same
property and what they did basically is
they have the femme nikita character
very much like lift from Nikita from La
Femme Nikita working with another
characters very much like James Bond
yeah like a but he's like out of mi6
yeah he's like a next time I see anybody
long but you end up with is the end of a
bunt with like a group of
ex-intelligence ages are ex spies
training a agents to go after terrorists
yeah but then it's like a big cluster
nobody knows who there's much you don't
know who's a terrorist sometimes and who
is it it's kind of it has elements of a
little bit of a murder mystery not
really its element it's a it's a spy
movie it's a spy spy broiler I guess you
would call it yeah I liked it I liked it
I liked it a lot better than that
what was it other ones like the copy of
'no fend akita made by the written by
the same guy anna anna is a lot better
Nana I liked it better than Anna as well
um just because I mean Anna wasn't a bad
movie either it just seemed like well
that guy already made La Femme Nikita so
why is he making it again yeah under a
different name yeah this one is very
similar to La Femme Nikita but one thing
that I kind of liked about it was that
her character who I mean her entire
family dies in in the ensuing three
years because this is three years
previously her you know family whole
family died in a car in a plane crash
and she was actually supposed to be on
the plane but she didn't go like at the
last like survived so she has like
survivor's guilt and stuff yeah and then
she so she's kind of like on a downward
spiral she was a drug addict she's a
prostitute you know so her life is kind
of like gone into the [ __ ] and she
really only gets kind of redeemed by
being approached by a journalist who's
like hey the plane crash wasn't an
accident like everyone said it was
terrorism you ever up may not want to
spoil the whole movie yeah I'm not going
to but so so that's kind of how she
starts you know you know building up
into like going after the people that
were behind the plane crash one thing
that I did like about this that was
maybe I guess it's similar to La Femme
Nikita but it's different from James
Bond in the
since that she is just a regular person
and you know at the beginning of it you
know she's a drug addict she can't fight
she's out of shape you know I mean she
can barely like run and [ __ ] like that
so they do kind of I do like that they
sort of addressed the fact that she's
not really physically up for this she's
maybe not mentally up for this there's
it's more of like a realistic well she's
not she doesn't turn into like this
super person you know what I mean but
you know that spy did turn her into an
agent though he did train her yeah you
know it didn't it didn't take he didn't
give her a whole lot of training there
was enough to kind of get her through it
but everybody kind of [ __ ] up
everything in this but nothing really
goes according to plan which I liked
because that was like more realistic
especially someone that had just had
kind of that minimal training yeah and
she was just kind of going on like anger
really is kind of what she was yeah
operating on Jude Law he's playing kind
of like a James Bond type character but
he's been kicked out yeah but he's still
operating yeah it's weird you know but
on the free Monday in freelance I guess
they're doing it for money yeah
everyone's kind of like mercenary yeah
and but now it's good flick it was worth
watching
yeah I knew thing with it is that it
pressed me that that ten-minute rule it
takes a while to get going very slow
starting and when you first meet the the
garl the woman what was her name again
[ __ ] Stephanie Stephanie yeah when you
first lay by it Blakeley she's not
interesting yeah really when you first
meet her and so it's like 10 minutes of
Moe penis yeah and you're like man come
on what's this and what's funny is that
when when the spy gets a hold of her
played by Jude Law you know he kind of
says you know it kind of it kind of says
that he knows really nothing to you yeah
and you know I don't want to support I
don't want steal movies yeah and like I
said it I that was one thing that I
liked that it was more real
stick where he's like well why don't you
just like play to your strengths I'm not
gonna like teach you all this
hand-to-hand combat Ellison he's like
because you're not gonna be that good at
that yeah and one thing I did like I
said he beats the [ __ ] out of her yeah I
mean she dude that's pretty realistic
right yet if she wanted to learn how to
fight so he just beats the [ __ ] out of
her like I said she's not you know and
he does say the thing he's like he's
like you know I've known women that were
just as good as a man but it's like I
don't think that you're one of those
people so let's kind of like play your
strengths rather than trying to turn you
into you know basically like a superhero
rut um you know you kind of ultimately
find out that you know that they're
playing for real yeah yeah I mean and in
the end he doesn't really care if she
dies or not yeah everyone's kind of like
which I guess could be a criticism
levelled at the movie is that it's
really hard to get kind of like an
emotional connection to any of the
characters because I mean as much as you
feel bad for you know Blake Lively's
character Stephanie because you know her
whole entire family is dead it's like
her life has gone down the toilet so you
can feel bad you know on a human level
but she doesn't give you a lot I mean
it's a good acting performance but she's
very stoic like she doesn't talk a lot
about what she feels she doesn't talk
you know what I mean so she's she's very
like keeps things very close to her vest
so in a way it's kind of like hard to
get in there yeah although I was like
interested enough in her journey like to
see what was going to happen you know
and I got interested in like all the
twists and turns like you said and I'm
like a lot more patient than you are but
even I was kind of like the beginning of
it I was kind of like okay what's good
you know it's like that she's sad I get
it verse 15 minutes you could have done
that in about three yeah like I kind of
I feel like that could have been like
edited like oh down a little bit um just
because it was unnecessary like you know
you can you can put yourself in the
place of someone whose entire family has
died in an instant like that um so you
don't really need to have like ten
minutes of a character just like
wallowing in it and being miserable one
of the things I did like about it is
that this movie was just now
moralistic they were all bad pretty much
yeah she was the one that was the LAT
least bad yeah but even she was pretty
bad
yeah everyone just around every day even
there are no real good guys are bad guys
so it's like moral gray area versus evil
it's kind of like evil versus evil witch
evil versus slightly less evil yeah
which that's the best way it really is
probably witch yeah and that didn't
bother me at all so like I said it's
it's not like some people have
criticized some of the criticisms that I
saw this may be like after I saw it
where some people thought that the music
choices were kind of strange and kind of
jarring yeah they were they were I mean
I I I always like have to give a shout I
love like that they use develop an
underground in there but it did seem a
little weird some people thought the
editing was a little weird that it was
very like choppy or yeah they put stuff
in there kindly tried to make things
kind of cool hip and light-hearted I
think but with a retro feel to it at
certain times but it's sort of like
atomic blonde yeah it didn't really
actually this is a real it's a downer
movie it says like this is kind of like
a bummer sort of movie kind so it didn't
really I mean yeah I guess in some ways
you could say like it's just the the
tone of it is just it's very downbeat so
it did seem a little bit strange like
yeah totally it seemed like a little bit
jarring there was gonna bother me that
much there's a good spy [ __ ] in it
there's some good action there was some
good intrigues we [ __ ] blew up people
that killed sneaky tricks and [ __ ] yeah
training nice like I said it's it's
nothing you haven't seen before it's
very similar to La Femme Nikita yeah if
you like La Femme Nikita and you like
James Bond you'd like it yeah you found
out as grand as Bob no I mean it kind of
does as a fraction of that budget it has
a lot of locations but you know it goes
like to Spain it goes to run and it goes
to Tangiers it goes like all over the
place New York I think it doesn't have
that same epic it doesn't yeah it
doesn't have that quality that wealthy
it looks good but it is not as epic as a
Bond film yeah it's kind of like a
grittier rut like you know shitty gutter
version but it's like so the person that
was a Mark Brunell here at this book I
guess he's written like a
I'm not sure how many there are but he's
written like a series of novels about
this character so I guess this is like
the first one and then this the rest of
them like kind of you know her other
contracts or whatever yeah but I guess
because this one did so badly that none
of them are going to be made now how did
this one do so bad it's only been out
for about a week that's what I mean well
I guess they expected it to make like 20
or 30 million its first weekend and it
didn't it made like 2 million um so like
I said this is like their lowest like
wide open a like wide you peace and what
like ever as far as I know yeah it's
strange because it's not a terrible
movie right and then in the DC Universe
they're bracing for impact with birds of
prey because the pre-sales on the
tickets are terrible evidently well like
I said I don't I'm I've liked like a lot
of DC movies but I didn't like all the
Suicide Squad and that kind of stuffs
that like really never interested me
like I know that like a lot about you
yeah I know a lot of people didn't
really like cyanide squad so I mean I
saw the trailers for birds of prey and I
was kind of like eh you know I'm not I'm
not like a big superhero or a comic book
movie person anyway like I'd like some
of them I like Shazam I like some other
ones like that but it's like just hey
man they're Naurang the fans and it has
to be kind of like a really you know
you're really amazing thing for me to
want to go see it like you know what I
mean it's even a lot of the Marvel
movies like are good but it's like I
don't really remember yeah what about me
like that was like a ride at Disneyland
you don't remember it I mean the best
Marvel movie I've seen lately was into
the spider-verse that's right which rule
was a good one but you know what I mean
and the best superhero movie I've seen
was actually lately was Shazam I like
Shazam yeah
poor Joker if you want to count that
yeah that's not real I don't really
count that it's like that's not like a
right I mean technically it's a comic
book movie but not really yeah that was
kind of more like a realistic yeah but I
think I think I think birds of prey we
might see it but yeah I might I mean I
probably see Suicide Squad first just so
I'm not completely opposed to that but
yeah like I said it's it's just not
really something that looked all that it
doesn't look interesting but I think
that's gonna be another Charlie's Angels
or [ __ ] ghostbusters mm
at 16 they maybe they bombed bad and
it's just
superheroes [ __ ] superhero movies
need fans yeah okay
and if you don't cater to the fans you
know you can't really push that to the
mainstream the mainstream doesn't give a
[ __ ] and that's something that people
don't but for some reason these studios
don't get yeah it's I feel like
something like birds of prey which is
kind of like an offshoot it's like this
isn't even the movie we're reviews yeah
yeah but it's like well it's something
like an offshoot I feel like that's
something that's sort of like a niche
audience and you really should like
cater to the niche audience I feel like
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I mean
that's so widespread that like
everybody's gonna go see that [ __ ]
whether they're into like the comic they
don't not but those suits don't realize
that catering to a [ __ ] catering to a
niche audience makes a movie authentic
and that in itself gives it the
credibility yeah to get people to go see
it to see what it was about if it's just
some generic [ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ]
yeah because if you're trying to make a
movie that like everyone will like then
no one's gonna like it that's just it's
just you can't please everybody you try
to please everybody you please nobody
just just an authentic generic [ __ ]
vanilla [ __ ] movie yeah because so
much Joker proved that if you call me a
lot Joker proved that yeah they [ __ ]
did something special everybody went to
go see that
yeah that's made like all the money yeah
world but yeah so the rhythm section
like I said it's in a way it's kind of a
shame that it's that it's bombing so
hard because it's really not like I said
it's not it's not bad a masterpiece or
anything but it was like perfectly
watchable it was like a slow start but
it's like after 10 or 15 minutes like I
really kind of got into it and I got
interested in seeing what was gonna go
and oh it's just [ __ ] like that's not
counting James Bond this has been the
bet that's the best spy when I've seen
this okay you know what this one writing
me a little bit to was remember when we
went and saw a girl in the spider's web
it's kind of a little bit along those
kind of lines - yeah that wasn't bad but
do you'll never see another one of those
yeah that's yeah you probably won't well
like I said the guy that wrote the book
the original books died so it's not like
he's gonna but yeah so if you're into
like I said if you want to see like kind
of a grittier version of James Bond or
something look kind of like La Femme
Nikita if you like spy thrillers or
something like that you might dig it so
you know
go check it out yeah
[Music]